police in central California are
searching for a gunman who killed a
local police officer 33 33 year old
corporal O'Neill Singh was shot early
yesterday morning during a traffic stop
in Newman about a hundred miles
southeast of San Francisco investigators
released these images of the suspect
taken from surveillance video he is
considered armed and dangerous
Mia viel is at police headquarters in
newman media good morning well good
morning there is a growing tribute to
officer sing here at the Newman Police
Department filled with cards candles and
flowers there is still no motive in this
case and 24 hours after officer Singh
was shot the suspect is still at large
ro Neel Singh had been on the newman
police force for more than seven years
when he was shot during a traffic stop
no name for the responsible the officer
to the officers name it was just before
1:00 a.m. when Singh called out on his
radio shots fired I've been hit
responding officers found Singh on the
ground shot several times he was taken
to a hospital where he died one of my
friends one of my buddies is you know
died doing his job and doing his job
protecting the citizens of this the city
this County's estate investigators are
asking for the public's help in
identifying the suspect captured in
surveillance video shortly before Singh
was shot his truck which still had paper
license plates was found in a mobile
home park outside Newman neighbors say
they recognized him I just seen him like
Pat when I passed by I just see you but
I never talked to him a native of Fiji
Singh was a k-9 officer specializing in
narcotics detection he leaves behind a
wife and five month-old son
members of this small community are
decorating the town with blue ribbons in
his honor Singh was just one of 13
officers on the local police force he
was really really loved I mean we love
all the cops here in town her endured
tour had been friends with the officer
for years he truly loved the outdoors he
loved his family took the time out out
of his busy schedule to truly follow up
on people whether it be a crime victim
whether it be a person that's buying
Donuts down the street or a fellow
just walking by there is no body cam or
dashcam video in this case and right now
police are having a hard time paying
down the identity of the suspect because
he allegedly goes by multiple names and
nicknames but we are expected to hear
more information about this case later
on at a press conference here in newman
at the police department
Tony Murray I think it's just a terrible
story